je suis la déléguée régionale aux droits
des femmes et à l'égalité du préfet de
martinique votre délégué national la
lutte contre les violences envers les
femmes
pour plus d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes est une priorité de ce
gouvernement avec la pandémie mondiale
il est indispensable pour se protéger
soi et pour protéger les autres de
rester à la maison
mais le confinement rime avec attention
alors autour de nous des femmes des
enfants subissent des violences
psychologiques physiques
c'est un fait je veux vous dire qu'en
groupe de partenaires associatifs et
institutionnels en réseau est
parfaitement mobilisés et
opérationnelles pour leur venir en legs
pour vous accompagner
oui au confinement mais non aux
violences que je gagne
bonsoir à vous pour lutter contre le
colis de 19
le confinement doit être respecté par
tout le monde
malheureusement cette situation peut
entraîner une montée de l'agressivité et
des violences de toutes sortes
on insiste on le sait à une augmentation
les violences conjugales puisque les
victimes sont elles aussi confiné avec
leurs agresseurs disait précieuse uni
vallée votre santé physique et
psychologique est précieuse
vous avez droit au respect les violences
sont punis par la loi
si vous vous sentez dénigrer agressé
oppressé ou en danger vous avez le droit
de paris et même de partir si la
situation est difficile
ne vous sentez pas seul parce que vous
n'êtes pas seul ou pas tous ces épisodes
nos caddies non non aux violences
conjugales la maison de solange espace
d'écouté d'information et
d'accompagnement de l'ue fmi est là pour
vous écouter vous aider vous accompagner
et plus particulièrement pendant cette
période difficile comme nous le faisons
depuis de nombreuses années n'hésitez
surtout pas à nous contacter
pendant le confinement liées au coût de
si vous êtes victime de violences
conjugales
il est toujours possible de demander une
ordonnance de protection qui vous
protégez vous et vos enfants
cette ordonnance de protection est
délivrée par un juge aux affaires
familiales du tribunal judiciaire de
fort de france sans dépôt de place au
préalable
néanmoins il est tout de même conseillé
le juge aux affaires familiales peut
prendre diverses mesures pour vous
protéger notamment l'interdiction du
conjoint violent de rentrer en contact
avec vous l'éviction de ce conjoint
violent du domicile conjugal en lui
demandant d'aller se confie d'ailleurs
mais également la protection de vos
enfants
n'oubliez pas pendant et après le
confinement vous avez des doigts vous
est le mois de fuir
n'oubliez pas pendant et après le
confinement
l'accès au doigt est à vos côtés vous
pouvez obtenir une consultation avec les
avocats du barreau de martinique
n'oubliez pas pendant et après le
confinement
vous êtes ultime et non en hauteur
culture égalité est une association
féministe qui lui tout au long de
l'année afin que les droits des femmes
soient reconnus qui est respectives en
ce temps de confinement se révèle et au
s'aggrave des problèmes lié à la
promiscuité à la précarité à la violence
conjugale
sachez mesdames vous pouvez compter sur
les membres de culture égalité vous
pouvez nous joindre tous les jours et
nous trouverons ensemble solution à vos
problèmes restés confinés
mais fuyez la violence
0 800 108 111 un numéro gratuit pour
toutes sortes de violences pour toutes
les violences faites aux femmes pour
toutes les violences faites aux enfants
pour toutes sortes de sons france nos
préventeurs sont formés à intervenir sur
soyez victime seront soyez témoins de
toutes sortes d'agressions
ne restez pas seul n'ayez pas peur nous
sommes là prêts à intervenir au
téléphone prévenir les secours le samu
et la police si c'est nécessaire
prévenir les autres associations avec
lesquelles nous travaillons comme le fn
l'alef pas la croix rouge
le cdad pour l'accès aux droits les
urgences ou psychiatrique pour toute
crise suicidaire
elles sont inscrits ce moulin épisode
confinement est pas remy épi violence
bonjour je suis l'amiable bonjour je
suis lié nous représentons la session
mon banc de nice est une association qui
accompagne des femmes victimes de
violences en particulier les femmes
victimes du système conçu peur du rhin
de confinement nous amplifions aux
actions est tentant de répondre aux
demandes de centaines de femmes qui nous
ont contactés qui se retrouvent sans
moyen de s'alimenter correctement mais
se loger correctement et nous avons
également mis en place une ligne
téléphonique pour vous soutenir
nous restons à votre écoute votre
pinceau
amazon est une association qui
accompagne les femmes touchées par le
cancer toute l'année et notre coeur est
serré à l'idée que tel en colo
confinement est censé être une solution
pour pour nous tous hommes femmes et
enfants de d'être à l'abri d'être en
bonne santé
malheureusement pour une partie de la
population et on pense notamment aux
femmes et aux enfants qui subissent des
violences
le confinement est loin d'être une
solution pour leur santé alors à ces
personnes à ses enfants à ses femmes qui
au quotidien doutes se font malmener
ce fonds aura baissé nous leur disons
qu'il existe des solutions
ce n'est pas facile mais sachez que vous
n'êtes pas tout seul plusieurs
associations se sont rassemblés pour
vous faire passer ce message nous sommes
là appelez nous il ya un numéro de
téléphone qui s'affiche passe un coup de
fil envoyé un message envoyé un texto
vous n'êtes pas tout seul
arrêtez vos kaiser protéger zot mèm si
ces petites antilles comme chapet compte
voisins voisines
j'étais en coudrier the paypal allait à
celui d'orly
mais pâques ou s'il est violent
mesdames vous pouvez être certaine qu'à
tout moment et surtout en ces temps de
confinement où tout paraît plus
compliqué vous pouvez être certain qu'il
y a des équipes un réseau d équipe à
l'aller fin qui sont là pour vous
écouter pour comprendre votre situation
pour venir vous chercher pour vous
hébergez vous et vos enfants jusqu'à ce
que vous puissiez voir plus clair à tout
moment il y a toujours une solution pour
que vous soyez en sécurité c'est le
travail de la leaf avec tout le réseau
parce que il n'est écrit nulle part
qu'une femme doit rester et accepter de
subir des violences chez elle si elle
doit partir il y à des équipes pour elle
qui seront là pour elle et qui prendront
soin de sa famille
bonjour je m'adresse aujourd'hui à
toutes les femmes qui ont été ou sont
victimes de violences sexuelles
ne restez pas seul le service
d'accompagnement des victimes de la
croix rouge française est là pour vous
écouter et pour vous soutenir vous
n'êtes pas seuls nous sommes là à vos
côtés